Hey, what's going on? It's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast.
Just before Friday.
Ah,
just checking in on you. I uh,
I got a special guest here.
I'm out here on the road. I'm
out here in Texas, you know,
came in and did Austin bunch of
hippy liberals down there with the,
that track colored flag, if you know
what I mean. All the codes though,
the Crayola box.
Um,
then we did Houston and hour in Dallas.
I am with the one and
only the pride of trend.
The best looking guy on long island.
Uh, ladies and gentlemen, Dude,
I called it Mr. Paul Versey himself.
What's up man?
Tell you what's up as a new
CD. Yes. Said is dropping.
I believe that's all the rappers and the
kids say hopping in less than 24 hours.
Yes. And it's called
night at the stand. Yes.
Because it was taped live at
the stand at this stand. Yeah,
we'll do it live. I didn't want to do
live, everyone's like live at this,
live at that. And I was like, you know,
I'm just gonna stick to Knight. Knight.
It's a stamp.
What did she do pre recorded pre
recorded at the Smith that Stan,
you know what was only like three,
three comics.
So I don't even think I would get
that joke. I a pre recorded wasn't it?
Me Mean he's making fun of it saying like,
oh you liked that little piece that
the uh, the piece of Shit TV's on.
That's a little art deco. Yeah. And
the TV is way too small for that piece.
It's unbelievable. That's like a
toupee. If I had a little yeah,
but a small to pay at my
giant Charlie Brown had,
that's what the fuck would look like.
That TV over there.
Me and [inaudible] had
been going to a Texas. Um,
I got here Sunday night and Monday. Right.
So as people know last week after my,
my 72 day run, I think I came up a
couple hours short of 72 hours. But uh,
I did 72 day cleanse because somebody
told me it takes 72 days to cleanse your
liver. And somebody told me on
Twitter it goes to it. It's 72 hours.
She fucking dope. I heard was
40 days, so I don't know. Yeah,
everyone's knowing that Jesus walked
through the somebody who was like 40 days
is when your liver is fully recovered.
Now 40 days is Noah's Ark with the,
with the, uh, with the shrubs. I wonder
why I fucking now and the yaks, you know,
you know me dude. I do not, I don't
drink for two, three days and I'm like,
I'm good. Let's go. Right. Yeah. Cigars.
I didn't, I didn't see me. So let's,
let's back up here.
Okay.
Those are what we just did was we
threw out all a bunch of numbers.
We've got to figure out what
these mean, right? 40 days. Yeah.
That was a Moses 40 days and 40 nights
he wandered around. Was it Abraham?
I bill and he led the Jews out of
the forest desert and find freedom.
And I do. I was one of those, cause I
didn't go to CCD. I didn't, you know,
my father always hard and I always argue
it's going to rain for 40 days and 40
nights duty.
Only thing I know about Noah's Ark because
he took a bunch of animals on a ship.
How much fucking was going on that ship?
He's got a male and a female.
It's fun and it's been a nightmare on
that ship shit everywhere. Animal Shit.
And they never see that
out of all the stories.
I didn't know, it just came
out like, did you ever see,
you ever hear how Joe Rogan's bid on that?
Joe Actually took the time,
which is why I love his act.
He actually took the time to research,
which I never do. How many species?
That's just just what we know.
How many species are on the planet.
Really? Yeah. I'd say it was,
it was well into the millions
and he would've had to
have two of each and he had
a guy like,
I'm not going to do it.
It just ended with this moron
guy just going like, oh big
ones. That fucking boat.
Just completely,
it's one of those religious arguments
that the other person would just say,
you're going to go to hell. I'm
praying for you. Cause they,
they would have no way to, there's no
robot that, that it's what anyways, Paul,
you know you're a tough guy
for me to hang out with,
cause I get along with
you so well and had a,
you'd like to smoke and drink and go to
the fucking I hop and all that and got,
dammit. That's what we've been doing it.
But let's just back up for a second. You,
you are a very big influence.
You're a bad influence to do them.
You're a bad influence.
You put this on me know,
because I see him here to promote your
album and you're going to do this to me
now I do it. You're one of those
guys where as soon as you go, yeah,
like when I know you're in, it's fucking,
dude. You're hard to keep up with.
Here's the thing about bill,
when you drink with bill,
when he really wants to drink,
it's just, it's never a no. Yeah.
And do you want to do another shot? And
you just go, you get that look. Yeah.
And once you do that, dude, I woke up,
I miss my kids. I woke up, it woke up,
my wife was ready to fucking divorce
me dude, because, oh that's right.
You kind of make,
you just kept going and I was like,
I'm not saying no to when I'm in. And we
were hammered first period of the game.
We went to the first one
that we were drinking.
We were particularly pint
vodka is that dude did.
That was the night you got to
to do George Stephanopoulos.
George Stephanopoulos can. It was
fucking Jeff Gordon. Oh, that's right.
You were a good friend. You Go
Virginia. I am not letting you drive.
You cannot drive it.
You know it's going to put,
you were so afraid of your
wife's taking your head off dude.
You are like movie drunk and I said Paul,
just lay down here for a
couple hours at least get even,
I can't let you drive there. Just sit
down. Smash cut. My phone's going off.
I look at seven Oh nine I was supposed
to be an hour north to get my kids and my
wife's going whereby I don't even want to
get it was, it was, it was bad. You know,
where have you been with the phone and
then dude, I did. You saw it though.
You did. Is He did do is,
yeah. You took some mustard
off for fastball. I did, yeah.
I sent her a cute text. Yeah.
Yeah. Put the blame on me. Yeah.
I told her I was a good son
and my friend help me out.
He took muster up for fastball.
He had to look out for it.
That was like that guy last night when
I got into that with that lady in the
crowd and we were really getting into
that whole debate about the wage gap and
then I looked over and I saw the guy
she was with their husband or something.
I felt so bad. I was like, oh my.
I was like, oh I was just like,
I heard you say that and I was laughing.
Yeah, that's great. I was like,
you got to drive home with her and
she's going to act like you said it.
And I just would say, and
I, I tried to take a little,
I felt bad for that guy cause
he was sitting there and
staring at me like, dude,
like really? I heard you say,
listen, the ride home going
to suck. But it's, it's me,
not him. He didn't say any of
it. That's right. And I said to,
it's just to let you know, while I was
saying that he was shaking his head going,
wow, I don't agree with this. I did
what? I could really shake his hand.
Now of course he didn't. Right. Well I
hope he's not listening to this coffee.
Then I was trying to somehow,
you know, I felt bad.
I felt like I did a Colby Bryan, you know,
Shaq does it too. You know what I mean?
It's dry.
When the fuck am I dragging him enough
fucking guys that are scared of their
women. It's fucking a
disgrace, isn't it? It is.
Unless you dating like Rhonda Rousey or
somebody would think I would be scared
of Ronda Rousey winning respect. I was,
what's enough? I was a Ronda Rousey.
I'm be like, dude, I gotta
get home. Rhonda said,
be home by 11 I ain't
fucking with the snow due.
My buddy interviewed her and she
has that thing where she's like,
she did that thing where she was like,
listen, I eat hot links with extra.
She goes, it was great. She goes,
I eat hot links with the extra hot
sauce and blue cheese. And she goes,
and if you're a man and you do ranch
and not blue cheese, I'm done with you.
She goes chunky blue cheese. And
that's what I'm saying. Okay.
So then he goes no repetitive back
to you to put her in her place.
I think it's just, you know, walk
in software out to who? Fuck that
Pussy Shit. I know she does it,
but I'm just saying, you know,
we all were guys where you're going to
piss her off and you know, it'd be funny,
a guy who starts to step up to her and
as soon as he sees that fucking neck
flare up, he's like, I have kids.
So here I going to go through,
I wanted to do a bit imitating,
like dating her.
I just knew my body couldn't take it
because I was going to be imitated getting
the argument and I was going
to flip over the stool.
You know like she does the arm bar thing.
Joe Rogan was backstage at the comedy
store trying to show me how to do it
without hurting myself and I'm just like,
dude,
I'm not going to do this every fucking
night. It would be fucking hilarious.
And I was going to be in the arm bar,
just call real mature.
Then when she goes for the chunk
of steel,
that panic yet when you can't breathe
there would have been fucking hilarious,
but it was just the level of pain that
I was going to have to go through to do
it.
It might be something I might,
I'll wing when now they've kind of said
the whole dirty your clothes and shit,
but just like, yeah, if she
was actually like abusive,
just you know what it might be. We
fucking brutal. Oh my God. Yeah.
She's a tough chick man. She's awesome.
I love her fights. I was saying,
cause you're a big box and god,
you were talking about how guys are
actually saying she's the first,
let's go home and let's watch the site.
The first female,
pretty much athlete that I've ever seen.
God, the guys are like, we're going home.
Look where we're getting the rousy fight.
Like that doesn't ever happen before.
It never fucking happened
before we was that Laila Ali,
Leila Ali was like the boxing
champion. She was great. She fucking,
she kicked the shit out of everybody.
But it wasn't like a, like Rousey's just,
you know,
she just goes in there like fucking like
fuck Tom Hardy did in the shit and then
to warrior. Remember that? Do you
remember that? Do you remember that? Uh,
that fight Tyson had,
where he knocked that guy out to
skinny guy who thinks he looks old now.
He looked like he was in
that movie carwash. Oh, well
Mitch Mitch, Blood Green.
He had that fucking Afro
Leftover on the 70s. Yeah, right.
And he fucking, when he got back
up and Tyson came running up,
it looked like he was like Dave Parker
trying to throw it in from the warning
track except what was it?
Overhand right.
And the guy just kind of like
try to turn his head sideways.
I saw a fight on ESPN and
it's actually on one of those,
a great knock out videos on youtube
with this woman did this to this to this
other woman dude.
And I thought she fucking killed
her and that was probably the best.
Like I actually tried to keep up with
whoever that fighter was like I'm gonna
Watch this woman fight again.
Cause you know I never seen a woman
with this kind of punching power until,
you know, Rhonda came along like
that kind of dominance suit,
this big goofy white girl. Right. And she,
she just fucking, she
hit her, knocked her out.
Like it was the full shot cold dude.
It was one of those things to
grafting and start counting.
He was just waving and the
girls stood over her, Jesus and,
and fucking like pelvic pump or something.
That was the only thing.
What was that about her, the
fight was just like, Yo, you know,
you might've killed a man, go
easy, go to your neutral corner,
standing over doing
like she did everything.
But you know that then that shit that
people do now where you're knocked out in
the street and someone takes that cell
phone picture like fucking two inches
from your face. She did
everything but that uh, um, but
yeah, there hasn't been, um,
it hasn't been anyone like us. So, uh,
I dunno. I Dunno how boxing, boxing,
boxing stinks. And I used to be, you know
me, I used to talk shit about you. US,
I'll be the first who, a minute I just
talk shit about UFC. I'm like, fuck that.
I want to see dudes barefoot. It's just a
blood bath. I got to tell you that they,
they're already getting,
when they were in the guard looked
like they were ready to have sex.
I'm fucking riveted now by that card to
the fights before rousing that night.
It was unbelievable. Yeah. Fucking
guy's face was just like a fight.
It was like a faucet of blood
comes out and he's just,
a fight is fucking unbelievable. It's if
it, oh, there was a couple of great ones,
dude. It was blood all over that undercard
hell yeah. There was a couple like,
I don't know how to fuck you. Dig
Heads fucking wide open. I was shy,
dude.
You when Dude,
let me go get stitched up and I'm going
to go get my real estate license. Ah,
dude.
Then the guy's nose was so broken that
he still fought with it and then he got
hit so hard with it already
broken and they had to stop.
But it was fucking brutal, man.
I don't know. It didn't say, oh,
what the fuck are we debating on the
way up here where we said it'd be a good
podcast. Oh, we can't talk about
that. God dammit so much shit.
And you just can't talk about me, man.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Oh yeah, the one thing to
the other thing. Yeah. Yeah.
It's not buck the land I wanted to
buy. I was on the way up there. Yeah,
I mean fucking Alaris so we're driving
up between Houston and Dallas and this
big sign it says 648 or
680 acres.com so I go,
I go look up that website. I don't know
what is 680 acres cost in Texas. Yup.
And uh,
it came out to a little more than it
was like 3,508 was 3,500 Acre Times 681
which is the accurate number. And it came
out to be like a two point $3 million.
I'll just highway land land
right across the highway. No,
it wasn't all the way down. I thought
it went in to do, went in a little bit,
but there was another highway
on the other side, right?
35 came on the other side
and I'll 35 away over.
Oh I don't know how deep it went
in, but I was saying like, dude,
that's unbelievable and you will live in
Paul's analogy. Cause I was just like,
dude, if you buy 10 acres
in Texas, it's 35 grand,
but 10 fucking acres, 600 to
seven acres, that's a town.
That's a small fucking town.
You can be mayor.
I want to buy that and start
my own fucking town. Right.
And you would go in like,
uh, no, no, no, no dude. You know, it's
what I wanted to fucking highway. I mean,
what were you going to do with, you know,
my thing is like guys out here in Texas,
like Cuban and these fucking billionaires,
they know that's out here.
They know what's available and it's like
for 2.3 which is a drop in the fucking
bucket, they're probably like,
no, what am I gonna do with that?
It's off the interstate.
Somebody wants to go to a strip mall.
I get a little fucking Dallas,
that's all.
I'm just going to go on a fucking daily,
you know,
far away Dallas's for most people.
First of all,
I'm not acting like I could
just afford to do that. I was,
I was just trying to see how
much land costs out here.
Then I was acting like
I could afford that.
And then he's gone into your logic
was, well, Mark Cuban didn't buy it,
so it's fucking bullshit.
It's like,
Mark Cuban didn't buy a lot of shit
right now. I know. I didn't know I began,
you know, then you got to worry
about the environmental people.
You got to put up fucking rest stops.
I'd rather you know what you do.
Here's what you do.
You buy a strip mall that's already exists
and you put the best stores in there
and that's all you gotta.
Then you gotta get rid of the
old guy with the shoe store.
The fuck do you do that? You get
to evict people. Uh, you know,
you gotta be Harley. He had a right get
it to get into commercial real estate.
You got to be fucking
heartless. Yeah, you do.
It was the wood Brown. Oh, here's
another argument we got into it.
Let's talk about, let's put talking
about sports cars now. Phil's argument.
Here's your argument. I called you up the
other day and we were talking and I go,
dude, a fucking, you know, you said
due to Ferrari or a Lamborghini,
he's just fucking Douchey. That's a
jerk off. And I go, it's not, I go,
it's fucking gangster. And you go, no,
because it looks good in the showroom.
No absolute 100% from top to bottom.
That is a fucking jerk off car.
And I'll tell you why.
I've never seen anybody do, listen, my
thing, if you take it from the showroom,
you drive it home, right?
And then for the most part,
you just put it on a trailer and you drive
it down to the track and you're going
around like fucking like Steve McQueen.
You coolest shit.
But if you fucking drive that thing down
the street to the grocery store to get
some bananas and pull in
right next to a fucking Prius,
you're a jerk off.
But that's the Prius has guy's fault.
No punishing this fucking guy cause
he's crushing it. No, the fight.
Don't know I'm not.
I'm saying what kind of a fucking Paul,
you're going to drive this $200,000 card
down the fucking street with pot holes
and all that shit. The Amish,
that suspension just alone.
I met front little fucking sin hits
the ground. I get it. But Dude,
I'm doing fact that someone like me in
a Prius can rear end you and then make
that face that, Ooh, sorry. Face that you
just had 180 grand. I'm telling you Paul,
it's a fucking jerk off. I'm
telling you right now, dude,
if I have $50 million on fucking pulling
up in a Lamborghini Diablo to fucking a
Carvel, I don't give a fuck who sitting
academically as Europe car. Now it's not.
I'm not a jerk off.
I'm a fuck.
Cause you'd be a jerk off enjoying
the fruits of my labor. Do it.
And this is a thing to pull.
You would crash that car because you
wouldn't learn how to fucking drive like
one hour, one hour, one hour, one hour.
You have it wrapped around a fucking tree.
Nah, you did a curve. Do these
all these videos on youtube.
Dude,
I'm not,
I'm not saying that I could handle that
fuck at two to five and got that car.
I would take it to a track and
I would hire a guy going, dude,
teach me how to drive this thing.
You can't go from a Camry to something
that goes for miles an hour. All right?
I think the, you're not going to
spin out and let me ask you this.
What car is enough for the street where,
where is your line get drawn?
Where as far as elegant a lot of money.
What do you think is not what she
would have to be on a Saturday?
The Porsche level around the house,
anything go beyond like the run
the hundred thousand dollars.
Do I even think some of those
fucking those, those, those 200 day,
you gotta look a $200,000 car
and you drive down the street,
your fucking chair cough.
You know, I don't know dude.
I just feel like you are earning Shannon.
I'm not saying you didn't earn it.
I'm not saying he's the guy
with the yacht. A journal. If,
if every other boats of fishing boat and
he's got this fucking thing that he's
out. Nobody takes it out in the ocean. He
fucking pulls into the south of France.
He's got fucking superman.
He's not just pulling into car Belk
sort of talking about right now.
If you get it, you have to get the
hard top cause you get the convertible,
the convertible's a chicken,
100% agree.
You can't have any charitable, yeah,
it's a chicken. It's a chip card.
Unless you got one of the older ones.
The older ones that what?
The convertible that are fucking cool.
But I like to be tops, but he stops man.
He tops. She got all of the skin. I mean
it's just, you know, that's like me.
Like I see a beer fun. My pasty
freckles. I don't even want to do it.
I got to go up to it. Yeah.
Canyons and Greeks. You get
tee tops. It's fucking over.
Oh yeah. I love white cars. The
older I get, the more Italian.
I love what you don't like what?
No,
I did a bit sane people who drive
white cars as scumbags, like cars,
like BMW, Mercedes. Oh yeah,
they've all dirt on me, Dude. I'm a
black car guy. A black is the color.
I think blacks are color and give a
fuck. People like guy, it gets dirty.
Fuck that guy. Man gets a
black car. We need a fucking
blue green. I mean I get it,
but for me it's gotta be black. If I
got a Ferrari tomorrow, it's black.
You're going to get black and I could
get the classic red. Nah, that's chill.
That weird fucking Christie
Brinkley in fucking Dan,
Dan and then a fuck that I,
I haven't settled is I love Ferrari's.
Obviously.
I think they were an
absolute fucking work of art,
but I think the only two places they
look good or in the show room or on the
track. Well, what about driving down the
street? What about a hold on a second.
What a corvette looks like. Not a street
car either and it's a fucking rocket.
I would,
but I put that in the realm of like
getting yourself like a Porsche nine 11 or
whatever. One of those.
Alright. Alright. Yeah,
that's about as fun as far as you can
go as far as you could go as a vet.
Then you'd say,
dude,
you have buy like a really nice suit and
brush up and get you get an a Cadillac.
Hey, you're all fucking nerve.
You can't even enjoy it.
People texting while driving and you're
riding down the street and like 300
grand you'd drive and basically their
house down the fucking street. Yeah.
Somebody is going to hit you.
Yeah. Now that you know the, the,
I like your point about the potholes
to especially like in New York City and
stuff like to do it fucking as a reason
to drive a Ferrari down a fucking
regular street is so people can be like,
wow,
look at all the money that guy has.
That's the only fucking
reason you think that though.
Do you think some guy's just fucked in
the cockpit of those fucking things?
If no, tell down to the fucking
track. You can go 180 miles an hour.
Do when you have a smile on your face.
Did that Sunday you'd smile smiling on
Thursday to an upward. Three more days,
three more days. I'm going to
get to do it again. Yes dude.
You don't buy a 200 to 200 fucking mile
an hour car to get on a highway where
the speed limit is 55 it's just fucking
stupid. And then on top of that,
they snow plowed and all this shit
that they didn't fuck the thing up.
Some giant 18 wheelers rubber
off their fucking dude.
I got tires laying in the road. I got to
tell you though, there was a guy by me,
he's got a white for
white or black Ferrari.
He drives it on a nice Sunday
afternoon around the neighborhood.
It's fucking crazy. Let's be amazing.
And he gets it up to 40 miles an hour.
No, I know, I know, I
hear. I hear your point.
But I would never punish myself cause
everybody else can't afford it. No, you,
you're missing the point.
I'm not begrudging that somebody
has it for the 50th fucking time.
I'm just saying put it on a trailer,
take it down to the track and really
drive the fucking thing, you know? I know,
but I'm not fucking waiting. I just
want to dry. Want a fucking go out.
Why you won't go [inaudible] I want
to feel it. Yeah, yeah. Till my wife.
Come on sweetheart. Let's go. Fucking
lets you know that's, it's stupid.
At that point you might
as well get a corvette.
Save yourself a couple hundred
grand because you don't,
you're going to be able to drive
just as fast. I'd be like, sweet.
Do you haven't see those?
Do you ever see those videos when they
show the Lamborghinis and the Ferrari's
driving through the country fucking roads?
Yeah,
and they're fucking doing like a buck
80 and all that type of shit too.
That's for the commercial shoot.
I guarantee you they got people out there
with leaf blowers and they smooth that
hold. It was like in the day when you
were, when roller, uh, roller skate wins.
Skate boarding first came out and
some assholes. Ah, go sweep the drive.
I don't want to see because
one little fucking level,
you see a flying. Yeah, dude,
you can't go 180 miles an hour down the
street with like tree branches and shit
in the fucking wrong. You're going
to go, if you're going to die,
we've got to find out how many
people didn't buy him a year.
I want to know that and look at,
look at them.
I'm not going to name the fucking things,
but there was that guy in the MMA,
he fucking died in one and there
was a guy from all those, uh,
fast and furious and those supercars dude.
And that was a professional driver
driving that Betty hit his stick. Yeah,
but here's the thing, dude, you
can't be going 130 miles an hour.
I don't give a fuck dude. Like, I
mean rest their souls and everything,
but that's tracking. There
was a box at the track. Yeah,
but even going that fast at a track,
if you're not a fucking
qualified to do it like globe do.
Could you imagine if somebody gave
me a thing of Dominique got to track.
It's like talking to a wall here.
I said I would buy the fucking thing.
I go down to the track and I have
somebody teach me how to drive it. Yes.
What I would do, I don't
know dude. I would just,
you'd go out and you go see
the next fucking, I'd go
out and visible. I would go,
I would want one sort of valley
it down at the fucking showcase.
Cinema
Sticky gummy bear hints
is work apart. I have total, I
think they were absolutely gorgeous.
Works of fucking art and dude, it would
be like, and to drive it down the street,
we'd be like buying the Mona Lisa
and hanging it up in a cabana.
That is an air condition
son getting on it and shit.
It's just fucking ridiculous. Uh, yeah.
Now my kids would fucking ruined it
too. Could you imagine? You know,
you drive down the street and they're
just paving the road for a couple of days.
They have the manhole covers up a
little bit higher. Uh, you know,
all of a sudden you turned
down that street. Uh, yeah.
You know, I get it. I get it.
Just say it. You're make a point. I just
don't think a guy, I just don't think you,
I think, I don't think the guys that
do or a jerk off, I will tell you this.
That's why I love the corvette, because
the corvette is the perfect, it's a,
it's a fucking supercar, but it's still
enough of a street car. You know, it's,
these still look stupid. If you go those
puddles of fuck you up to an event.
Absolutely. Yeah. Apps, the
fucking movie, Dude. I mean,
you can get into a corvette
for like 60 grand, 50 grand,
60 grand. You're in there.
He can get a fucking insane one for
like 90 or 100. Yeah, Dude. Yeah,
that's about it. You can go out there
three and a thousand dollar car.
I would have sound of that
fucking cave in the quarter panel.
Yeah, but what, just a sound above, oh,
that would be sick. Ah, yeah, but in,
in the frost,
you wouldn't feel frustration.
He could never get out of second gear.
I'd be a fucking dope and I get a ticket
the first time of the fucking highway I
was,
as I'm talking right now,
you'd fucking peel around a corner
and you would go right up on the curb.
Fucking oil pan.
Plus they pull it up to a comedy club
and then on the way home at night,
I'd fucking ended up going to
a buck 20 getting a ticket.
My wife would fucking kill me.
I'd get like set 12 points in my life.
I always ever doing a one 20 in a
Lamborghini or Ferrari and the cop came up
like, what's the, what's the right?
What do you mean for that Ferrari?
What's do you mean dope? Look what I'm
driving on the door. What the fuck?
He was like, you don't do that and you
want car. Every time you turn the lights,
you have a call. We'd have the fuck
Outta here. Sketch. What are you doing?
We need to come down.
It's a supercar. Yeah.
He caught me sneaking over
those chicks and cannonball run.
You'd have to fucking hope it's a gay
cop unbutton a couple of years fucking
button downs. All right, so Paul Versey,
he has a new album coming
out called please buy it,
man. I'm really proud of him.
I'm proud of it. It's uh,
we uh, did it. It was, uh,
April 9th on Thursday. We sold out
two shows. Uh, people came out.
It was great and I'm really
proud of it and buy it, man.
It'll be available tomorrow. It's my first
one. It's my debut one. And Yeah, man,
I hope I thank everybody.
Did a lot of people pre,
pre ordered it and it dropped soon,
so I was kind of nervous when you're
first time you put in something out,
I'm kind of nervous, you know, you'll
be fine. You'll be fine. It's great.
Now you know what? You got Paul,
you've got an asset. You invest,
you invested in yourself. You know
what I mean? Thanks, Bill. Makes a lot.
All right, so I'm going to do a
little bit of advertising here, right?
A zip recruiter. Everybody, uh,
identify the pain of hiring a as a
business as that's supposed to be for me.
Oh,
I guess this is a point to identify.
I should have like reverb on
the pain of hiring, hiring,
hiring as a business out of your company's
only as good as the people you hire.
A posting jobs in one place isn't good
enough to call to find quality candidates.
Short staffing leaves a little time to
post to dozens of jobs, sites, positions,
zip recruiters as the solution was
this for the person writing the copy.
Why is this in here?
Can Post to 100 job sites
with one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates
from over 6 million resumes.
Plus Watch brand new candidates roll into
ZipRecruiter's. Easy to use interface.
Uh, within 24 hours. Ziprecruiter has
been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Uh, today you can call zip
recruiter for absolutely free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/bar,
ziprecruiter.com/bar. All
right, next issue. Everybody.
Next issue. Your time is precious. Paul's
your time precious. Absolutely. Yeah.
You know what, you want to feed your
mind with the best of what's out to it,
don't ya? Why wouldn't
I? Of course you do,
but who has time to sift through all
that nonsense on the Internet, not me.
Oh well you go well for us who want to
use premium content and don't have time
to waste finding it. You know what there
is Paul glints net. There's next issue.
Nice asked me what it is.
What's next issue bill?
Well next issue is the mobile app that
lets you tap directly into the world's
most popular magazines.
Anytime,
anywhere using your phone
or tablet you don't say,
I swear to God they got all your favorites
like sports illustrated, maximum x,
squire,
a frog international and
next issue and next issue,
but she died.
Somebody up isn't the frogs and next
issue lets you dive deeper into the story
with interactive content
not available anywhere else,
giving you a richer reading experience.
The best part,
next issue was offering a free trial.
Right now when you go to
next issue.com/burr up for
next next issue. Right now.
You'll get immediate access
to all the top magazines,
including back issues and
exclusive video photos. Again,
you can try next issue for free right now.
When you go to the next issue.com/burr
all right. What do we got left?
Here we go. Is this one more?
All right. Okay. Here we go.
I always sing a song with this one. Jumped
in if you want to. Okay. All right. Yeah,
me undies, everybody, but oh,
boat, boat, me undies, me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
Some of the photo for me.
You can check them off down at the mall.
Shaggy fucking cock.
Then put them back on in.
Your Dick will be dry and then go get
yourself a doughnut. Hang it on your Dick.
Jesus.
With this fucking pair of me on,
these are we all know how sexy confidence
can be. Do you find that sexy fall?
What? Confidence? Nah.
You don't find confidence.
Find it arrogant. I was kind
of Bitchy, right? Yeah. In
a woman is arrogant. I take,
wait, that's awful, but Sunday where for
men. Oh, okay. Yeah. Then conferences,
I guess,
and that confidence comes
down for being comfortable.
But how great can you
feel if your underwear,
it's wrinkled and riding
up on your fucking team
gets it?
Everybody designed it has a
tape and that's why they've
created the world's most
comfortable underwear for a
daily dose of concept confidence.
You wear underwear every day that Paul,
come on.
If you walk around with saggy underwear,
your balls are just staring at the
floor, right? Yeah. No you're not.
You're going to ask you actually
ask for that extra buck an hour.
You're not going to do it. That's
true. 65 days a year, rain or shine.
You need it to be extraordinary within
within an insane price. Tag me on these,
understands this,
and that's why they've created the
world's most comfortable underwear.
Luxury at half the retail price you
find anywhere else when you look good.
God Damn it. Paul. What do you do?
You feel great. You feel great? No.
When you look good, you feel good. No.
When you look good, you feel good. Good.
You look great. When I look
good, I feel great. Oh,
you do make me on these
Mandy's no more sweaty balls.
It's a cliche because it's true.
Me.
Andy's understands this and that's why
they design underwear that makes you look
and feel fantastic. Please include
all the following points. Well,
what the fuck he wrote it.
I'm going to read it. Um, me
undies. System mode. Modal,
modal. How would you say M O. D.
A. L model. M. O. D. A. L. Yeah.
They don't put an accent. They write
it all in lower case. M o. H my doll.
My Dell. Yeah. Mandy's is made from model.
I'll go with that. It's, I already know.
He's a fabric that's twice the softest
cotton. Mudhal no fucking nuts.
It's like that tennis
player, Nay Dell. Ah, yeah.
Not The de oh, no doubt. No
doubt. That's what it is.
It's more dal got a go to moves.
Remember that? Mandy's, ah,
that's twice the softest, whatever
underwear you're wearing right now.
And he has tons of colors and styles.
The only place to get matching
pairs for men and women.
They even released a new
design every month. Uh, I
were fill in the blank design,
black stripes tied I et cetera.
Plus we all know that paying for
shipping sucks. So order me undies. Uh,
it has removed from the equation.
So ordering from me and he says,
removed that from the equation.
All orders in the U S and Canada shipped
for free. Mian he's Jesus Christ.
Just sold them already.
Me undies even has a money back guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair,
you get it to keep it for free.
You literally have nothing to lose. Oh my
God, there's one more as one mark, Uber,
everybody. Hey, do you like
making great money? Hey Paul,
it was weighted so sleazy.
Hey Paul, he liked making
money. Money, right? Oh yeah,
yeah. Come over here. Listen,
he's a really cool opportunity
I had to share with you.
Don't look around throwing around
driving with Uber.
Duke. Imagine some guy showed
up in a fucking Ferrari, Uber.
Uber's that popular, smarter holes in
the back. Oh yeah, just some board.
Rich Kid fucking hate my dad. I'm going
to make my own money. What we're saying.
And then he finally realizes that
everybody doesn't have a Ferrari.
What was that popular smartphone APP
that connects writers with drivers?
I take Uber a bunch.
Evidently I loved them evidently by the
way and in chatting with the different
drivers,
some of them have really interesting
stories is why they drive with Uber.
My Bitch, Jack's wife took the kids.
They love being their own boss.
They earned great money. It's easy to
start. You just need a car and a license.
Driving. Driving with Uber is great for
anyone who needs flexibility. Parents,
this is a really easy way to work around
your family. Schedule students. Ladies,
you can make some extra money between
classes. Get off that stripper pole.
Now's the prime time to
cash in and drive with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling
you how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your
car when you drive with Uber.
God knows I'll be hammered.
It's the only time I use them and
think of the lives that they save.
Call to action.
You got a car and a license.
Put a boat to work and start earning
serious life changing money today.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com that's drive
with uber.com drive with uber.com.
All right. Oh my God. Sorry. 31 minutes
Paul, before we get out of here. Yeah.
Thank you for being on and we've got to,
we've got to have your
NFL picks for this year.
A super football picks at the beginning
of the year where my showreel picture of
the beginning of the year where NFC Green
Bay packers AAFC Indianapolis Colts.
Okay. You're feeling good
about the packers? Uh,
I I'd say at the NFC
is completely weakened.
I think that I'm Russell Wilson and
you're fucking loud stadium jerk offs.
The Seahawks, I feel like they,
uh, they're not the same team.
The 49 are actually though. They
started slow last year. Yeah.
I mean they got Sham Canceler
Kam Chancellor back at safety,
so that's going to help
them. But it's still, I don't
think they're the same team.
San Francisco,
40 niners not the same team.
I could tell you my New York football
giants, as much as I hate to say it,
they're not the same team.
Cowboys Lost Romo.
That's a huge hit at the time to press
the panic button in New York. Uh,
not yet.
But you know,
then we'll see what happens with Dallas
Eagles are not shift Kelly and eagles
there. Their little fucking plan hasn't
worked. The only my guy, Sam Bradford's,
my guy, I still believe in him.
Do you want to leave it in him?
You've been believing in him for a long
time and do it and I gotta tell Ya,
I hope got one year left
brother before it becomes, yeah,
I saw one of your big picture. So I
was fucking steak house the other day.
So yeah, dude, I take Aaron Rodgers,
you know who's playing good.
Your boy Matty ice over there.
The falcons are playing good,
but I still like end of
the day gun to my head.
Aaron Rodgers is fucking
unbelievable. I like him. Now,
here's why be the Falcon fans
can actually chair this year.
So they don't need to pump in all
that extra crowd noise. Right.
I've got to throw that in. You know,
if we're going to get out. I don't,
but I don't blame me. Um, but I do it. I
thought Andrew Luck was going to be there.
Started out real bad this
year, dude. So I don't know.
And you guys with the fucking shit.
I should've known better every time.
I think the Patriots are going to, not
that I thought they were going to take us,
but fucking with that deflate gate.
Brady's like fuck you. Seven touchdowns,
two games. I mean, it's a joke.
It's a fucking joke, dude. Yeah.
They'll come up with something.
Jim would say,
we'll come up with some other
ticky tack Horse Shit to say.
That's why we beat them by 50 fucking
points. Yeah. Yeah. He's a baby. He's,
yeah, but let's look what's
going to happen. I mean,
look at Brady's doing already
to having people learn,
but it's early having people learn
to push a patriots. Yeah, just keep,
let them do it. It's great. He's offended.
Then they get the US against them.
It solidifies the team.
It's fantastic. I'll do,
one of the funniest
things was when you guys,
after that fucking spygate when you guys
went into buffalo and it was like the
night for the guy that was paralyzed.
It should,
they have them on the big screen to
you guys won like 55 to 10 or so.
It was so crazy. And they as Bella check,
cause he was so defiant after spike,
it has check.
They're like,
why are you going for it on fourth down
near the goal line when you're up 21
points. And he goes, you know, it's only
three touchdowns. Like he just fucking,
he was oh yeah, he doesn't
give a fuck dude. Yeah he does.
He definitely does not.
Well a unfortunately. Dude,
we got to wrap this up so fucking quickly.
Uh, you've been crushing it, Paul,
with the new stuff on stage. No thank
you. I mean you'd be at best stuff.
You just keep getting better.
I appreciate it man. You know,
I knowing the level of applause you
get before I go. Well, you know,
you don't get open or applause. Uh,
if I appreciate it man. Well Dude,
I have been fortunate enough.
Let me make you uncomfortable now.
I've been fortunate enough, that's the
whole idea. Why a compliment, by the way,
by the way,
I just got to save.
You guys are coming out to Dallas or
Toronto bar is full of San Antonio level.
They last night I literally was like,
how are these people not tired?
Judge the fucking act out the new bit
with the, I don't know. I get into it.
Let people come and see. But
yeah, it's been a lot of fun
and uh, yeah, it's, it's,
I've learned from the best
man. It's a, and we w what
are we doing on Saturday? Oh,
then Saturday we're going to the
UT. Oh, come on. Oh No. Yeah, yeah.
I'll come home and cook them horns.
Thank God the net play at Tcu to see good.
Come on. Frogs come out. Frogs. Yeah.
And they show up when they dress.
Like they were born with
silver spoons in their mouths.
So immediately they're just annoying.
I'm sure the nice piece people,
but they fucking were like
these blue dress like jr Ewing.
Remember that showed Dallas.
Yeah. Way Back in the day. Yeah.
It's like that minus the hat
and they have these dumb shoe.
I found the Texas longhorn fans when
we went to the red river rivalry.
I've found them fine. They were
cool when they do the horn thing.
I felt way better than Allah. Vans were
cool too. Yeah. Alabadle the fans. Clay,
the Texas a and m fans who,
cool.
You didn't like Alabama fans
because the kid was in a low for,
and then we got into that. I almost
got into that fight with that kid. Oh,
I can't deal with, I can't deal with that.
Uh, that fucking like that Jorge rate.
Look at a game.
Fuck you.
My Dad's the a fucking head
of the division and about
to fucking chick that jerk,
the guy off in a real quick,
I don't want,
there was a chick and she was at a fucking
football game and she will look out
for a guy. What happened was her
boyfriend went to go get beers in,
his guy was sitting there and he kind
of put his hand on her leg and she said,
I was really creeped out,
but I kinda liked it.
So she didn't look at them and apparently
she jerked him off until he finished.
Right when the guy came out,
she was never kind of creeped out.
She's covering her fucking ass.
So she sent a letter kind of
game does that other guy has,
she said a letter out and she
goes, hey, if you know who I am,
I was the girl sitting next
to you and this and that.
And I kind of liked it and I want to and
I'm reaching out and like fucking tried
to reach out to them. And like, right
when the guy fucking busted in his pants,
she fucking, the guy boyfriend came back
with peers. Could you fucking imagine?
Wait a minute. Yeah, dude, did he at least
have a winter coat to the people doing,
sitting right behind?
They don't notice it until I got a
bunch of fucking animals at a game.
She probably just had the fucking hand.
They're doing it. You know what I mean?
It's fucking crazy. And she fucking
like reached out to the guy.
He fucking imagine that. But we're,
well, we're lucky. We're lucky.
Here's the last thing I'll say. I
know we got to go. The one thing that,
and this is not against, you know, I
mean, I love my wife too, you know,
he is hilarious.
I sorta got any story about women
or anything within two seconds.
You just gonna be like, you know, he's
actually right now not to do it. Do.
That's a great sooner. I love
my wife. Okay. I love my dude.
Great for what you want to stay.
But the fucking thing that irks the shit
out of me is where the lucky he sold.
Oh my God, what? What are you
doing without her? He's so lucky.
Won't he do it out or how have I driven?
That's I said,
how have I driven not going
into accidents? How have
I not gotten pulled over?
How lucky you know what in
the back of their heads,
the what they're trying to do. Paul, when
are they lucky? He's a fucking great guy.
They can't do that. Why?
Yeah, they can't get no,
because we have so many options.
Paul, you understand that?
Do you understand that when like
you know we get later on in life,
you get divorced at 50 Paul. Okay.
With what you're doing and everything,
you got a shot. It's still
fucking tagging the 30th 32 Sam,
once they hit a certain age,
they get ready to,
are you going to bang a 50 year old woman?
No.
And you just went through a Rolodex of
famous women uterus sitting there. God,
I fucking do this. Yeah. This
is how we're wired. I think.
I know and I think I even really
even know what I just said there,
but it sounded really dumb,
I think. I just think women,
I just think women think men are lucky.
I just think they put themselves higher,
dude. Sometimes I think it's really
fucking selfish. I think you know,
it'd be great.
When's the last time anybody's wife
listening to this podcast right now?
grabbed your fucking hand look in the eyes
and said, you know something? I'm so
fucking lucky to have somebody like you.
You know what? I'm so lucky. It
doesn't, it doesn't fucking happen. No.
That usually happens if once you give
them the cold shoulder cause you're onto
whatever game that they're fucking
planes true. Then they come back,
they're like cats,
same fucking thing.
The cat's been all country around
the house. She just be conceded that,
that thing right back and all of a sudden
they're fucking weaving in and out of
your legs. It's exact same fucking thing.
If you're nice to them, Kimmy. Yeah,
but yeah, they just fucking look at you
like a piece of shit and I love, I love,
I love when you, when people go,
what would you do without her?
You know what he'd be doing without,
you know exactly what I would
be living in some studio now.
He'd be living at some
studio, like a bachelor with
a fucking, oh, he'd be awful.
You know what he would be do you saved
him? What, what would you be doing?
What would I be doing?
I think,
I think I would be smart enough at this
age to know not to buy a leather couch
cause I hate in the summertime,
the sound of the back of
your legs getting off of it.
You've got to always make sure
the acs at a certain level,
so it still go with like
this type of material for a
fucking guy would have that.
I would have all the fucking
sports packages, right?
I build a drum room already know what
I do. I think, give me a fucking,
why would I do to listen to my wife?
My wife would indulge in drinking and
smoking and all my hobbies. That's,
that's what would be like my wife has been
amazing to me and she's fucking great.
But I, and she's helped me with a lot
of things. Um, I think I would smoke.
I think I'd smoke a lot more than I do
because I smoke cigars a lot and I'd
think I'd smoke more. You
had to be smoking life force
third. You're an animal.
Yeah, Dude. I, I think I smoked for
cigars the first two days of the tour.
I tried to smoke too with you and the
next flight and the next day, dude, I,
I felt like I had stood behind a bus.
Yeah.
I can't believe I smoked one the next
day with you just because you were doing
it. I was like, dude, I
didn't even enjoy it. No.
I think my wife has definitely
made me calm down with some things.
I would drink a lot more.
I'd probably be a lie.
I'd probably be out of shape more.
I mean, I'm not in great shape,
but I think if I was alone, you know,
it was hilarious. We went too hard. Uh,
like we always do the
first couple of days,
now we were supposed to go to a movie
on a relaxing day off and we go,
you know what,
let's go get Tex Mex for lunch and
we'll just have a 10 hour elbow seat,
black matte, and then we'll go see black
mass smash cut two hours later. You know,
I did the movie. I know, fuck the movie.
We're doing shots at Don Julio fucking
Tequila and were drinking all fucking
night. You sitting at a
sports bar and they had like,
they had baseball on
the Yankee game was on,
they had some soccer on the name of the
replay and then they had this just like
fails like youtube fail.
People fall into choices and shit.
And I was just the first part, I'm going
to leave this to go see a movie. Oh yeah,
we've got those tacos. I'm still going
to go see black mass without a doubt.
But I mean I'm, yeah, and I want to see,
I want to see it too. It's been good.
But we were good last night.
We were gonna let you know.
The funny thing about you last night where
like I don't give a fuck what anybody
says, dude, I'm going home. Listen, I
don't care. You know, if you want to go.
And I was like, no, I'm with
you too dude. I'm tired too.
And then all of a sudden in between shows,
she just got you.
Just give me that look and I know
you're gonna you know what that means.
And they got and he goes, Oh
boy, second wind. Oh yeah, no.
Once I go out and have a
good show and I feel great,
I want you want to go out and you have
a couple of parts. Well fortunately,
and unfortunately I got a lot
of friends here in Dallas,
so I don't know how good I'm going to
be tonight, but I will tell you this,
when a, once I get to this one,
when I get off the road, uh,
I gotta get back on it because,
cause what,
some students took me three months to get
in shape and I sorta got fucking three
weeks.
I'll give it all back.
So I got to make sure Jesus
Christ what the are in here.
Well thank you for having me.
Yes,
no worries Paul versus these
albums tomorrow drops tomorrow.
I had to stand now available on iTunes
and a band camp and a soon to be on
Amazon and Spotify and thank you to
all things records for doing the right
thing, all things comedy. But the record
label is all things record, so thank you.
Prerecorded life, Paul
Verses. All right, let's see.
Um, this is what I did this
week. People, I came home and uh,
I don't know what the
fuck I was supposed to do,
but I walked into my bathroom and I saw
that I had a leaky faucet immediately I
got excited because I was like,
oh my God. I was like, oh my God,
there is a problem.
All right,
this is a problem and I know how to fix
it. I know how to fix that motherfucker.
All I do is I unscrew that little thing
that the faucet handle pops right off
and then right underneath it set thing
that looks like a fucking spark plug.
Right? Pull that thing out, this
little Washer, you take it out,
you stick a new one in Bam. And you
reverse the process. I've done it,
I've done it like five times
since I've been in this apartment.
And by five I probably mean to,
but we're going to say five.
Okay.
Reality was probably too, but I feel
like I've done it like five times.
So I walk in there, bring in
my little toolbox, like a fair,
I bring in and that little red one
little fire engine, red toolbox.
And I come walking in,
you know,
looking like the puppet that I
look like and I open it up, right?
Grab my Allen wrenches, unscrew that
little fucking thing. And here I am.
It took the screw up. I did everything
right. I put the towel right up,
down in the sink, right over
the, uh, the drain mouth,
so I wouldn't lose it down there.
I put the screw white where I knew it
was going to be right in the little area
where I brushed my teeth. Everything's
going well so far. All systems go.
So I unscrew the fucking thing right?
Everything's good.
And I go to take the handle off.
Lo and behold, it won't come off.
Seems a little fussy. So I, I
start jiggling it a little bit.
I started tugging at it. I go,
wait a minute, Bill, wait a minute,
let's not break anything and turn this
easy. Repair into something bigger.
So what do I do? I go on to youtube
already getting embarrassed going,
I already know how to
fix this fucking thing.
I was going to show off that I know how
to do this. So my girl could be like,
oh my God, you're so, you're
funny and you're handy, right?
And it would just fill up my ego.
So I go on the fucking
youtube how to a leaky faucet.
And every motherfucker on there,
they're on scrolling a little screw.
The handled pops right off and they're
onto the job. So I'm like, son of a bitch,
maybe there's some sort
of a gunk in there.
So I started tugging it a little fucking
harder. And in the back of my head,
it keeps going. Don't do this,
it's going to break. Don't do this.
I start looking at it going,
did I,
did I take a wrench out or
was there something else I
had to fucking unscrew it.
I just can't figure it out.
And finally what happens?
I lose my temper and I go, I'm yanking
this mother fucker rough, right?
What happens? Snap the God damn
handle. Snap the fucking thing off.
Like halfway down,
part of the threads are in there.
It's this old vintage
fucking faucet handle.
So I had this simple God damn
job. Oh, halfway through.
I called my fucking dad to death to
figure out how to do it and I was already
pissed. Which is funny. Isn't that funny?
When he calls somebody at midway through
a job, you know, he's just hanging out.
He's a psycho. Hello Mike. Yet bill,
I'm trying to fix the fucking faucet
and he's just like Jesus. Easy, easy.
You know, you just hit the ground
running, screaming at him. Oh I,
you know what you want to do?
Their bill is, yeah, you want to,
why you want to unscrew? And I'm
like, I fucking did that already.
I already did that. I tried to do it. When
he go out and jiggle it, I jiggled it,
you know? And I yelled at him so much, he
started getting mad and he's like, well,
fucking call a plumber. I'm like, I'm
not going to fucking call a plumber.
I'm a goddamn leaky fucking
faucet. And he was like, well,
I don't know what to tell you.
I said, fine, I'll call you
later. He goes, all right,
goodbye. You know? So that was the
upside of it. I got a little father,
son, quality time, quality time
in there. So what do I do? I say,
fuck this.
I got gotta,
I got a God damn screwdriver and trying
to force the whole time I'm going one
step that I miss. What did I do? Did I
just push this up here? Sorry about that.
I'm like, what's step that I just
fucking miss? So as you know,
was always my temper does mean,
and what do I do?
I fucking Yank this thing off.
It snaps off and now I still have a
leaky faucet and I have half a God damn
handle. So, of course, you
know, the male ego, I can't
say anything to my girl, right?
I just fucking walk out, head down to
feet. I look, you know what I look like.
I look like fucking Peyton manning in
the third quarter of a playoff game.
I got that Peyton face,
you know,
I ended my chin strap and I'm already
looking for somebody to throw her under
the bus to blame it on,
right.
I start blaming my landlord because he
likes everything all fucking old rather
than just,
you know,
putting the blame on my shoulders and
being a fucking leader. So like I said,
I walk out of there.
That's the only thing I was missing
was a Peyton Manning Jersey.
As I walk out my stupid sweaty forehead
and I just walk out and I wait for Nia
to it,
right?
And she comes in and she
knows I've been flipping out.
She heard me yell at my dad
about a Washer, you know,
stupid fuck another
three minutes of my life,
I'll never get back because
of my dumb ass temper. And uh,
she goes in and immediately comes out.
She's like,
what happened to the
sink was are you like,
are you halfway through the
job? Nope. It's done sweetie.
Still leaks and now there's half a handle.
Anything else you need
me to go take care of?
Here I am the man about the house. So, um,
anyways, so I've gone on, I've
gone on Ebay, I've gone everywhere.
I'm trying to find, it's not a
really unique, a faucet handle.
It's just an older one. And out of
respect for the guy who owns this place,
I want to get a new one.
Does anybody,
any podcast listener and my loss and in
the Los Angeles area know where I can
find?
Do they have all the Zeros?
Is there a Fred Sanford House out here
that just so I have a bunch of old faucet
handles? That's what I need to know. Uh,
I have pictures of my damaged faucet
handle up on the, uh, the MLM,
podcast.com,
the official fan page of the Monday
morning podcast. And once again,
it's www.themmpodcast.com.
People seem to be having problems
sometimes finding it and uh,
anybody out there that
knows how to fucking do it.
If you could look at it and
tell me where I went wrong,
even took a picture of the goddamn
screw where I unscrewed it.
What else would be holding it in?
I don't understand it.
Obviously you don't understand it,
Bill. You fucking broke it. So, uh,
I'm embarrassed.
It's one of the first things I learned
how to do and plumbing and I was beyond
excited. I probably talked about
it three years ago on the podcast.
For those of you searching in the
archives, um, I don't want to have this,
this is a lot,
but what kills me about that is
that is a microcosm of my life.
It's like there's an obstacle.
I learned how to defeat it and then
I walk away and I completely forget
everything that I've learned.
And then fucking six months later,
I'm in the same situation.
I lose my temper and the
thing blows up in my face.
And uh, you know, I'm 43 years
old. So who's kidding who,
when did you say I'm beyond
the halfway point in my life?
You've got to think that.
I mean, 86 years, you know,
that's long enough for
a curse. Everybody. Um,
I think I'm going to make it into my
nineties that I want to hear everybody
talking about my temper and how
it's causing high blood pressure.
Go Fuck Yourself. I go for hikes. That's
how I even the salary level it off.
Yeah.
We've got, oh, let's do it. One one up.
Why don't we do the rest of the
youtube videos for this week.
We got some great ones.
That will be@themmpodcast.com.
Please remember to type in the,
we'll have all these youtube videos
right there for you so you can just sit
there surfing the net. All
right. This is a great one.
Texas man gets a $330,000 home for $16.
This, this is one of the
greatest stories I've ever seen.
This guy found a loophole.
Basically,
the guy who owned the house
declared bankruptcy. He took off.
Then the bank had it and I can't remember.
I only watched the video once.
There's something about this,
this loophole in Texas where if a house
is abandoned for a certain period of
time,
you can file this form.
It costs 16 bucks and
you can claim the house.
And this is what this guy
did, right? It gets better.
Everybody on the block is pissed because
they paid like 330 $350,000 for their
fucking houses. Houses,
sorry. At this guy comes in,
he pays $16 for a house. So it
brings the value of their house down.
So they want him out of there.
Not only for that reason,
but I'm also guessing cause it's a
black dude and they're all white.
Just I'm telling you, it's like
when I watched this, I'm like,
this is the greatest beginning.
It's like a pilot episode for
the greatest fucking Sitcom ever.
Like the amount of characters that you
could have. It's a fucking TV show.
So basically what this guy has to do,
he has to stay there for three years
and and that the people on the,
you got to watch this video that his
neighbors that trying to get them for
everything,
they're like,
well we just think he should pay for his
house like everybody else. It's like,
you know what? What? What
sort of a team player are you?
Just because what you signed yourself
into indentured servitude to these piece
of shit bankers.
One Guy,
one guy gets out of it.
It doesn't have to become a fucking
slave to these assholes and you can't be
happy for him because he found a
loophole because he did his homework.
If you read a body,
you could have owned two houses,
you could have sold your house and then
moved into the other one for 16 bucks.
Quit hating on the guy.
I think it's the greatest
thing ever considering these
backers took this bailout
money. They don't eat. They don't,
not only do they not know where,
they don't know where it is, the can't
say where it is or who even got it.
And the,
the breaking this guys,
that was like a billion trillion fucking
dollars would have this guy 330 grand.
You're mad at that guy.
He's a fucking genius.
You know what I would do
if I lived on that block?
I would give that guy a fucking Goddamn,
I don't know what I would
make them a Bundt cake.
Whatever the fuck you supposed to do,
I'd welcome them to the neighborhood.
Okay.
Aye. Aye. And I'd be like,
listen to, can you do me a favor?
Can you read some more documents?
And if you come up with some other shit,
I would love if you could find a
loophole that somehow affects my life.
Like, like there's the, the totally
overlooking this guy's talent.
You know,
you know what's funny about that guy,
that black dude and moved into that thing.
If he was actually on TV screaming about
how I bought a house for $60 half the
people on the fucking street would call
the one 800 number in order his God damn
book. You know? And then if
it turns out to be a scam,
okay,
you'll never see the guy again,
right? The guy is on your block.
He's right there.
Go over it.
Learn from them.
All right, here we go.
Hey, Bill. I met with this
girl for a year and a half.
We broke up for about a month recently,
and this month she dated another
guy from April to May. This.
Okay. That's plenty of
time. Um, to do the deed.
Sometime around the beginning of May,
she started texting me and calling,
begging for me back.
She told me she didn't want,
she didn't do anything with this other
and she wasn't thinking when she said Yes
to going out with them.
Also,
she told me in this month of being
together that they didn't do anything
sexually. All Jesus, he said that
himself. I like how this man thinks.
Uh,
we've been back together for about a month
now and we recently have signed a one
year lease on an apartment
together. Oh Gosh. Uh,
about a week ago she told me that she
did have sex with this other guy multiple
times. Oh, Jj says this.
I'm just reading word for word what he
wrote here and she thinks she may have
gotten an STD from him,
so that's the only reason
why she came clean.
Oh Jesus did I mention that me and her
are 19 and the other guy is 32 you know,
dude, you're 19 I can see
how this happened to you.
She failed to mention this to me too and
failed to mention that she thinks she
has an STD before we had sex
multiple times. Bear back
when we got back together.
I don't know what to do.
I'm stuck in a one year lease with a whore
and I might have an STD. What do I do?
Sorry. This is long. This is what you do.
You stop having sex with
that woman immediately.
You and your relationship with her
immediately you go out and you get tested
immediately. I bet you don't
even have it. I bet you don't.
Okay. If you've got herpes,
it's going to show up. Right?
I'm going to shut the fuck up
because I don't really know too much.
If you got gonorrhea or you got syphilis,
it's you have,
you have fucking urines going
to hurt. Something's going
to happen. All right. Um,
I think what happened was she got back
together with you and then somewhere she
lied saying that,
um,
she didn't have sex with this
guy and then all of a sudden she,
something happened. Did
you got HPV? I Dunno.
What the fuck something award a soar.
Something popped up and she said,
Holy Shit.
She went to the doctor and found
out she got an STD. All right.
So now she has to fucking tell you.
Okay. Because, uh, Jesus Christ,
this is such a fucking mess.
This is such a mess because you know
what this girl is, she's too young to be,
to be like, uh, she's afraid to be alone.
The second you break up,
she goes out with somebody else and
not just goes out and bang somebody.
She goes out and has like a fucking
relationship with this guy. All right?
Then immediately runs back to you and
then signed a one year lease so she can
fucking feel safe. And now she's with
you. And now she drops this bomb on you.
This is what you do. I don't know
if he can get out of the lease.
Is your landlord a guy?
If he is,
have a face to face with them after
you get tested and tell him that.
And maybe you'll luck out and just
say, dude, can you do me a solid?
Can you do me a solid? The very
least, if you can't let me out,
can you let her out? I don't want to
live with this girl for the love of God.
Maybe you can get out that
way. If not, you know,
I say you walk,
do get yourself tested.
You know,
get yourself tested and then fucking walk.
All right?
But this is such a fucking
harsh lesson to learn.
You just don't have unprotected sex.
You just don't.
Okay.
You just don't and you don't sleep with.
I know you didn't know she was a whore,
but just in general,
you just don't fucking do it.
You just do it. Just don't
do it. All right? Just,
just don't do it. All right.
That's a fucking horrific story.
I hope it works out good for you.
Um, you saying you might have an STD,
so I'm guessing you're doing the typical
guy thing where you're not going to the
doctor immediately. Go to the doctor,
get yourself tested. All right,
drop to your knees and thank
God when it comes back negative,
which is what I'm thinking it's going
to happen and everybody on the podcast,
how about we all say a collective prayer?
All Jesus for this kid.
All right, let it come back negative.
Let it come back clean dude,
and just get on with your fucking life.
All right?
Please tell me this. Horror
is paying rent. Jesus Christ.
I mean Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ.
Then you got to [inaudible].
Now you're gonna have to fucking break
up with her and then you'll live in in
the same place. Oh my
God. What a nightmare.
Then he got to meet other girls. Fuck
that dude. It's only a year. Your Life.
You're only 19. Jesus Christ. A lot
more worse things can happen. All right,
I'm sending you positive vibes.
It's coming back. Negatives,
have a fucking talk with,
with the least guy.
Tell him you're fucking shovel his
driveway every time it snows until 2018 or
something. Just let me Outta here. I gotta
get Outta here. I gotta get Outta here.
All right, please. For the love
of God, let me out and uh, and,
and have at it with her, but whatever
you do, wear a condom. All right.
Good luck to you,
sir.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].